pièce maîtresse de la manifestation
annuelle femmes
envolez-vous le siba vda voue une
passion extraordinaire à sa discipline
préférée
aujourd'hui vice présidente de la ligue
de volley entraîneur joueuses des aigles
blancs son club de toujours
celle qui a remporté trois médailles aux
jeux des îles 79 83 98 est un porte
drapeau exceptionnelle pour la pratique
d'un sport qui lui a permis il y a
plusieurs années de faire partie de
l'équipe de france féminine de six
professeurs de psc aujourd'hui qu'elle
peut transmettre son enthousiasme et sa
réussite au fait depuis quand cet
infatigable militante pour le
développement de sa discipline at elle
découvert le volley ball
c'est une longue histoire c'est dire et
c'est une passion avant tout parce que
je continue à jouer avec la même envie
le même plaisir et quelquefois je me dis
à tenter toujours gagner mais tu vas
jusqu'à quand tu vas continuer il faut
que je m'arrête bientôt je pense parce
que vu mon âge c'est pas que je ne peux
plus le château pour laisser la place
aux jeunes je pense et surtout qu'il ya
des jeunes qui ont la possibilité de me
l'apprendre
en fait c'est donc mieux française m'a
donnée qui m'a inculqué l'amour du
volley-ball ses fonctions de régaler à
venir jouer bon ça c'est passé
accidentellement le premier entraînement
mon frère qui est sportif et qui joue et
enroulée qui un jour m'a prise à la
sortie du lycée qui m'a dit viens avec
ta tenue de sport je savais pas où aller
alors c'était étonnant et j'ai débarqué
comme ça au volley ball hockey des
aigles blancs et j'ai joué je me suis
entraîné au bout d'un mois j'étais en
sélection de la réunion et voilà ça a
commencé comme ça et puis il ya eu le
grand départ pour les études à
montpellier le club du muc la section
universitaire française spinosi son
entraîneur comme marc ses qualités et
lui donne de la confiance nécessaire
pour franchir de nouveaux paliers
la timide e réunionnaise des contres
alors qu'elle a un talent nationale et
tout s'enchaîne et donc l'année d'après
je me retrouve à l'as ptt montpellier
nationale 1
je fais une saison je rentre en vacances
à la réunion et une semaine après je
reçois un courrier vous êtes convoqué un
stage de présélection nationale
alors ça je n'ai même pas réfléchi j'ai
dit aux parents écoutent et je fonce je
parle c'était une présélection faut bien
le préciser ce qui veut dire que au bout
d'une semaine de stage et la sélection
qui tombent ou la non sélection
bien sûr j'ai participé à ce stage et je
dirais le plus grand moment c'est à la
fin de ce stage quand on m'a annoncé
vous êtes tu es sélectionné alors là à
ce moment là j'ai pensé à toutes les
tous les réunionnais en fait et je me
suis dit je vais rentrer la réunion
seulement pour leur dire c'est possible
parce qu'en fait on arrive à la réunion
en métropole on est peut-être on se
sous-estiment dans un premier temps et
puis on est timide
c'est un peu le profil du réunionnais
timide on est loin aussi de
bondues contexte familial du contexte
facile je dirais qui permet peut-être
d'évoluer et de se dire en est à l'aise
et c'est vrai que bonds pourraient avoir
des obstacles mais on peut facilement
avec la volonté surmonter ces obstacles
et donc j'ai envie de dire tout ça aux
réunionnais en leur disant écoutez moi
je ne suis pas une sur ruben je ne pense
pas et on a autant il y en a beaucoup à
la réunion qui ont ce profil là et qui
pourrait percer au plus haut niveau donc
sélection nationale donc faire partie de
l'équipe de france pour moi ça a été
vraiment une des grandes joies de ma
carrière on entend la marseillaise
retentit roux jouer la marseillaise
c'est vraiment un plus quoi ça donne des
frissons c'est bon on pense à la réunion
moi mon premier réflexe est pensé à la
réunion je suis fier d'être réunionnaise
je suis fier aussi de représenter la
france et je pense à mes compatriotes
réunionnais je veux dire on l'aide à
niveau des transferts métropole
justement à vivre cette passion la halle
en shérif t4 en métropole et je dirais
deux ans en équipe de france
alors après je suite à mes études je me
suis devenu professeur de ps donc mon
premier poste était à piton sainte rose
à la réunion parce que je n'avais pas le
choix de toute façon j'aurais bien aimé
rester à montpellier parce que c'est une
ville que j'adore
le problème c'est que quand on est
sortant professeur de ps on va au nord
de la france c'est à dire au dessus de
paris lille ou dans l'est et toute façon
j'avais quand même envie de revenir chez
moi pour enseigner le ps donc aux
réunionnais et aussi pour dire aux gens
que bon
le volley ball au plus haut niveau le
sport au plus haut niveau est accessible
parce que vous trouvez que le volet est
reconnu est ce que c'est un sport
reconnu par rapport aux autres à la
réunion parce que on n'en sait pas c est
ce qu on n'en parle pas c'est
trouvez que c'est très bien comme ça au
niveau des médias et ça a démarré
et puis je pense que le beach volley
nous aide énormément l'apparition de
cette activité qui est quand même une
annexe du volley ball le beach volley
bon ça apporte un côté fun ça attire
énormément de jeunes
je vois que par exemple en unss qui est
le sport scolaire
il ya deux ans nous avons fait un beach
qui devait regrouper deux mille
participants
nous avons eu deux mille participants il
ya tout tout un programme qui est mis en
place
surtout au niveau des jeunes nous avons
une action jeunes qui est primordial
parce que on pense qu'en s'investir sur
les jeunes à long terme ça a payé
nous avons aussi une liaison avec la
métropole c'est à dire par
l'intermédiaire du centre régional de
formation et des pôles espoirs qui
existe en métropole il y a un côté
formation formation du joueur
j'en ai parlé déjà et une formation le
cadre qui est aussi la formation de
cadres qui est primordial nous avons
énormément de jeunes qui pratique le
volley ball actuellement et nous devons
avoir les cadres qui sont qui doivent
être à la hauteur de ces jeunes
oh
septembre 2000 à l'étang salé la
deuxième édition de femmes
envolez-vous connaît un gros succès des
femmes d'horizons divers viennent pour
passer une journée de détente le site et
son organisation sont sur la bonne voie
en fait la première édition ce a
regroupé les femmes sportives non
sportives les femmes alors je
commencerai plus par les femmes du sport
adapté et les femmes handicapées du
handisport donc et les femmes sportives
et non sportives tout le monde était je
dirais noyés dans la masse et ça c'est
quand même un point positif c'est qu'en
fin de journée on s'est rendu compte
on n'aurait peut-être pas dû qui avait
dans le tournoi de beach-volley par
exemple des femmes du sport adapté et
qu'elles se sont noyés dans la masse et
qu'on les a pas vus donc c'est vraiment
elle se sont intégrés je veux dire elles
sont intégrées et ça quelque part ça ça
donne du baume au coeur
je pense que le projet il doit évoluer
d'une année sur l'autre à lens et à nous
avons reçu l'équipe de mayotte
c'est important de le dire parce que le
faut savoir que le sport féminin est
existant mayotte
donc nous avons nous avions invité pas
mal l'équipe extérieur la réunion des
dom-tom de métropole et mayotte a
répondu
présents donc c'est très bien les femmes
qui sont venues se sont régalés elles
ont été vraiment surprise par
l'organisation a travaillé sur cette
journée ça m'en voulez vous
l'année dernière nous étions quinze
femmes et c'est vrai alors bon chacune
avec ses moyens avec sa disponibilité
donc chacune s'est investie et on a un
bilan à l'euro ce qui est bien c'est que
les femmes rentrent vraiment dans le jeu
et à la fin au bilan elles font leur
autocritique
il ya des femmes qui sont entrés dans le
comité directeur de la ligue
réunionnaise de volley ball
en fait ce projet qui à plusieurs je
dirais facettes 1 et qui a plusieurs
objectifs
un des objectifs principaux c'est bien
sûr la prise de responsabilité de la
part des femmes au sein des associations
et au sein des différents conseils
d'administration
donc vous êtes le maman de combien
d'enfants ici j'ai trois enfants
d'accord j'ai trois enfants dont une
petite dose étant alors et une grande de
14 ans
alors j'ai deux enfants qui pratique le
volley ball
valérie et andrea qui ont 14 et 10 ans
la petite dernière plutôt allergique au
volley-ball je la comprends parce que
bon allez toujours se référer d'abord un
visa pour l'info oui et puis elle fait
d'autres activités en fait nous avons eu
comme principal
dans la famille c'est ouvrir des
possibilités aux enfants un maximum de
penser possibilités je savais que tôt ou
tard elle allait venir au volley ball
nous n'imposons rien en fait
et elles ont choisi les deux grandes en
ce moment elles font du volley ball
elles font autre chose si comme activité
d'autres facultés et la petite bon si
elle est allergique au volley-ball et
qu'elles préfèrent à le badminton
pourquoi pas alors au niveau de ma
famille c'est vrai que bon c'est un
équilibre à trouver
alors fais aussi beaucoup de présence
alors les devoir m'occuper des enfants
avant tout et me libérer alors les
traîneaux qui sont à moi propres je
dirai ce sont les entraînements de voler
voilà quand je joue au volley alors les
gens sont persuadés année jamais chez
elle non je suis chez moi
souvent avec les enfants et mon mari est
les seul petit créneau où je suis à
l'extérieur ce sont en fait le seul
petit fils quand je joue au volley ball
ce sont les seuls créneaux où je me
consacre à ma passion
alors le premier message c'est par
rapport à femmes en voulez vous je
dirais aux femmes bon que ça fait partie
de
de commandes d'une hygiène de vie je
pense de pratiquer une activité sportive
dans la semaine ou deux fois par semaine
je crois que ça fait du bien ça permet
de libérer le stress donc pratiquer une
activité sportive
le deuxième message s'adresse aux jeunes
pensée pensée et ceux qui peuvent je
vois j'ai une élève qui mesure 1 80
doses qui a le profil qui peuvent percer
au plus haut niveau il faut foncer
surtout pas se mettre des barrières en
disant je suis réunionnais j'aurais pas
mes parents ça va être difficile mais
oui ça va être difficile mais c'est
tellement une joie une grande joie je
veux dire se connaître le plus haut
niveau c'était appréciable je dire